[Music]
out there
yet you can't go wrong with robocop oh
amazing
um so i'm going to start with i thought
you did a fantastic job in this movie
i really i really mean that sincerely
um how does snake eyes see out of his
mask
when he is when it's fully there uh and
it's just like a tiny little bit of room
i'm just curious if you could share that
that mask
is form fitted to my enormous skull
um so it was a task to
to sort of take off putting it on is
absolutely fine because they
they enclose it completely but taking
off without
destroying this beautiful artwork was my
greatest fear um but uh but in fact
it's reasonably easy to look through
with with the visor
there are sort of slits that you kind of
kind of kind of see through
but i'm sure with the with the the magic
of movies
that uh that there's going to be some
sort of head display
and um you know it'll be easy peasy for
someone like snake guys to see through
that
got it i was always wondering when you
uh
i'm assuming you auditioned for this
role um
um actually it was it was more
uh they approached me to have a meeting
with robert and and for me and him to
sort of
hash out kind of what the ideas
of this movie would be so for for them
they
they they really went out on a limb um
to presume that i could do all
of this which is which i was like
wow they uh yeah they're brave but
luckily
you know i i myself had enough um
sort of faith in in my physical
attributes to be able to be like yeah
let's
let's get the training done let's make
it look badass and i'm sure you'll agree
that the stunts are
absolutely insane so uh they
they they definitely they did some sort
of research somewhere that i wasn't
aware of that
they knew that i could do this well
that's the thing like i actually
um i love the fact that there's like
these wide shots and there's
shots that clearly show it's you doing
stuff and it's andrew doing stuff and i
think that adds so much
to why i enjoyed this movie that it's
not trying to cheat
you know obviously there's stunt
performers in this let's not pretend
of course but um what actually goes in
for you getting ready for a movie like
this talk a little bit about what the
training actually is and how many months
out is it
and let me start with that yeah so we we
did
um two about two months of
pre-production
um in vancouver um and that
included a boot camp with kenji tanagaki
and and his crew of of samurai
experts like he's he comes from samurai
x uh live adaptation of raroni kenshin
and so that that sort of sword play
was synonymous with his his type of
choreography
so we got the exact guy we needed um
to make all of this look badass but it
was
a solid four hours a day every single
day with
uh like an hour and a half two hours of
script work after that
um and you know it doesn't stop
from when you start filming because of
the amount and the number of fight
sequences there are in the movie
you're doing it for a solid five six
months afterwards
um so you have to keep show up you have
to keep that mind sort of moving
with with learning the choreography so
um
it was a it was a crazy process but you
find you sit in the zone
and nothing else kind of matters and you
get so kind of
i suppose buried in the work that uh you
just have these blinkers on
which which you don't even have to
concentrate anymore it's kind of like
let's do it what are we doing now
how can we make this better and bigger
and more explosive
what do you wish you knew on the first
day of because this is your first big
movie like this
what do you wish you knew on the first
day of filming that you now know
um i i don't think
anyone is aware of how much goes into
a movie like this you know there are
of course action films with gun work and
running around jumping through buildings
and things but the
preparation needed for something like uh
snake eyes
is is amazing it's you really have to be
diligent
in your um in your in your learning
and so like the movie you really have to
drop your ego
um and understand that these guys these
people that we have
are the specialists from all around the
world the best stunt crew
so you need to learn from them to make
yourself better
um so it's yeah i think it's it's it's
leaving
leaving the ego at the door and coming
as a as a student
obviously without getting into spoilers
um you do not perish in this movie
they obviously are aiming to do sequels
uh
what do you hope gets to happen in
future installments
i hope that we get to see um
the brotherhood and the strength and
the ferocity the
competitiveness of both our
very amazing characters in snake eyes
and storm shadow i want to see that
blossom
uh and i want to see where that leads
because we leave it
in this movie at a point where it's just
like give me more i need more of this
film
um and that was that was the goal it was
to
tickle the taste buds um and and make
people yearn for more
one of the things i i thought was cool
is that uh cobra
and gi joe are both in the movie but
they're not
in the movie if you know what i mean um
so talk a little bit about what uh uh
i guess what you're hoping or what do
you know has this has lorenzo told you
anything
or heard anything about you know
future things on how this could happen
you know future plans
lorenzo de bono ventura keeps his cards
very tightly to his chest
um but the what what i loved
especially with your comment uh was the
fact yes it is
wholly focused on the human element of
uh the gi joes and that's snake eyes you
know this is his
origin movie but you get to see the
world in which
he lives and that is the gi joes and the
threat of cobra
but it's not overwhelming it's it's it's
it's definitely a factor in in the
entire story
um but for but for you as a viewer
your sort of concerns uh and and
worries are really about uh the human
element behind the man behind the mask
um so you you're kind of rooting for
that but at the same time being
being sort of teased and tickled
as to what is out there in the bigger
world and we sort of see
uh near the end of the film him
taking his first steps out
to see the expanse of what is yet to lie
uh i have i'm not talking to robert so
i'll ask you um did you have a lot of
deleted scenes in this
we've got a tremendous amount of deleted
scenes like like much much like every
every film
you overshoot the action um they're like
i'm sure there's tremendous amounts of
sort of scenes that we had to cut back
on
just for running time to to not sort of
over glorify the violence but uh we have
we have so much uh to show
uh that we filmed that we weren't sadly
able to fit into
into the movie um but that's like every
film
you gotta make the best with what you
have and sometimes
you you've got to leave stuff on the the
cut room floor
blu-ray um anyway i will uh stop there
obviously i'm out of time i'm just going
to say it again and i really mean it you
did a great job
uh and i hope it's a huge hit for you
guys i appreciate it thanks stephen
have a great day bye